[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aime la science
j'aime la science pour ses grandes
découvertes j'aime la science pour sa
promesse d'un monde meilleur
j'aime aussi la science simplement parce
qu'elle nous permet de voir l'invisible
devoir l'infini je suis docteur en
physique
j'ai passé de merveilleuses années à
faire de la recherche
pourtant pourtant la science me fait
peur la science me fait peur pour des
raisons éthiques et techniques la
science me fait peur aux multi présent
quid des ressources dépensées quelle
finalité aux recherches
ce sont des questions qui vous concerne
tous et pourtant vous ne connaissez rien
à la recherche
vous ne savez pas ce que les chercheurs
pensent écrivent prévoit alors ce soir
je veux lever le voile sur cette
recherche a levé le voile sur la science
et vous permettre de prendre en main
votre avenir
pour faire face à l'obscurantisme michel
serres a identifié trois révolutions
majeures dans l'histoire de l'humanité
la première celle de l'écriture puis
l'imprimerie aujourd'hui la révolution
du numérique avec elle le savoir est à
portée de clic
l'ensemble des connaissances de
l'humanité sont accessibles depuis chez
vous c'est absolument fantastique
c'est fantastique mais pourtant ça ne
suffit pas savoir ou plutôt su c'est de
pouvoir savoir n'est pas suffisant il
faut pouvoir comprendre il faut pouvoir
faire la science c'est pour ça que ce
soir je vous propose de devenir des
citoyens chercheurs je vous propose de
vous impliquer dans cette réflexion dans
cette recherche et de participer aux
sciences citoyennes
ces sciences participatives aujourd'hui
sont inexistantes mais pourtant je suis
persuadé qu elles peuvent être un
lobbying puissant qui peut contrer les
groupes de pressions politiques et
industriels qui peut résister à ces
pressions
alors demain les citoyens en
s'impliquant peuvent être les acteurs
majeurs des révolutions du 21e siècle
qu'elles soient économiques sociales
environnementales
les prémices des sciences citoyennes
c'était hier
c'est la mise en réseaux de milliers
d'ordinateurs à travers le monde pour
une cause commune en 1999
autant dire les moyen-âge d'internet les
sciences citoyennes se sont développés
pour chercher des extraterrestres et
grâce à ses pairs ces précurseurs votre
ordinateur vous aujourd'hui pouvait
contribuer à la recherche dans de
nombreux domaines lutte contre le cancer
anaïs climatique et bien d'autres alors
c'est un premier pas mais c'est un pas
majeur mon histoire des sciences alors
impliqué vous participez à cette
démarche
mais il faut aller plus loin et pour
aller plus loin je vous propose une
métaphore aujourd'hui ce soir je suis
l'acteur je connais les coulisses je
connais les détails je représente le
chercheur qui connaît son laboratoire
qui connaît sa recherche vous
spectateurs
vous avez accès à une partie de ce
savoir vous voyez la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
vous êtes le citoyen averti et puis je
peut interagir avec vous vous êtes
plutôt thé ou café
ceux qui répondent sont les citoyens
avertis et les citoyens impliqués
et puis à l'extérieur de ces de cette
salle l'extérieur de ses murs il ya la
masse des citoyens qui n'a pas accès à
l'information
cette masse de citoyens tend à se
réduire avec notamment avec les
nouvelles technologies la route racisme
en vidéo
les messages sur les réseaux sociaux etc
et je vous propose de faire disparaître
cette ignorance et pour cela il faut
tomber les murs de cette salle il faut
tomber les murs des laboratoires alors
comment faire
et bien en collectant vous même les
informations scientifiques et en voulait
partageant entre vous en vous impliquant
dans cette dynamique vous aurez accès
aux données
vous aurez accès au savoir qu'ils sont à
portée de clic et puis vous avez accès à
des calculateurs puissant ordinateur
smartphone tablette avec ce triptyque
données savoir calculateur vous êtes
intégration
fyk vous êtes membre à part entière
d'une communauté qui s'ouvrirait alors
sur le monde qui s'ouvrira sur le temps
sur le futur et sur l'univers ainsi en
2016 de nombreuses choses sont
collaborative on parle de crowdfunding à
propos d'énormément de domaine
financement jeu jardin et bien d'autres
pourtant les sciences participatives
reste encore balbutiante
deux exemples le premier l'étude des
comportements alimentaires et leur
impact sur la santé
vous êtes mis à contribution quasiment
quotidiennement par ses études et vous
attendait une réponse des 10 rue dit
dans dix vingt ans impliquez vous
impliquez vous y accélérer ce processus
et demandé à ce que ces données soient
libres pour pouvoir les contrôler
deuxième exemple l'étude de la pollution
des mesures existent elles sont libres
c'est bien mais elles sont encore
parcellaires
alors on avance on avance il faut aller
bien plus loin ce que je vous propose
c'est un monde où vous pourriez
collecter des données une qualité
équivalente à celle des laboratoires de
recherche
c'est l'abattoir de mesures un monde où
les données collectées seraient libres
et explicités pour vous permettre de les
comprendre
quel que soit votre formation un monde
vous pourriez utiliser ce big data
mondial pour faire vos propres travaux
de recherche
alors il ne s'agit pas de supprimer le
scientifique de métier bien sûr je vais
pas couler le bateau sur lequel je suis
moi qui n'ai pour survivre que mon
doctorat et mon couteau mais il s'agit
plutôt des pôles et les scientifiques
il s'agit aussi de contrôleurs
travaillent parfois mais surtout il
s'agit de nous enrichir de votre
diversité alors serait vous tente il est
à portée de main ces capteurs qui
permettent de collecter ces données
quantitativement et quantitativement se
peuvent être accessibles dès demain les
développer mon métier et on n'y voit
aucun obstacle les infrastructures
numériques
qui permettent le partage des données
existent vous les utilisez déjà
quotidiennement
pourtant il manque un ingrédient les
acteurs vous c'est à vous de faire ce
choix c'est à vous d'entrer dans cette
dynamique
alors comment révolutionner la séance de
demain
eh bien vous citoyen dans la formation
scientifique
c'est peut-être arrêter ou lycée
engagez-vous collecter les données
vous êtes le maillon essentiel de la
chaîne sans vous la science restera
obscures vous êtes 99,2 % à ne pas être
scientifique à ne pas être chercheur 99
2% imaginer la diversité dans ce prix la
recherche en vous excluant alors nous de
notre côté chercheurs
[Musique]
ouvrons-nous sur le monde ça nous
souvent mal compris mal perçue à juste
titre souvent et puis tout ce qu'ils
peuvent
chercheur bien sûr mais aussi
techniciens ingénieurs travailler à
rendre ce monde transparent
il faut créer un lien entre le monde
réel et la science la recherche un lien
exempt de toute relation financière
un lien exempt de tout lobbying alors
participé à cette dynamique
donc c'est donc faire un choix mais cela
fait de vous un citoyen ou planté en
collectant les données en participant
vous acquérez un sixième sens imaginez
alors les corrélations fantastique que
vous pourriez découvrir ensemble les
orages solaires influe-t-il sur votre
organisme
la météo influe t elle sur les qualités
nutritionnelles des fruits et des
légumes
peut-on révélé la matière noire avec des
milliers de détecteurs de radioactivité
ou mieux peut-on prédire les
tremblements de terre avec ces mêmes
détecteurs et s'il vous ensemble était
prix nobel en 2026
[Applaudissements]